I was recently thinking back to the
intro of Hogwarts Legacy and trying to
figure out what makes it work so well
regardless of how you feel about the
rest of the game there's something very
special about that introduction I'll
certainly never forget my first time
playing and just being totally blown
away at how they made us feel right at
home in The Wizarding World
again what is it about this intro that
works so well for anyone who's played
the game you know there's a very
specific moment we were all waiting to
see it's a moment many of us had
imagined since we first read the books
or saw the films for the first time when
people engage in The Wizarding World
what's the one anchor like what's the
thing that everyone comes back to what's
the thing that grounds it all and
grounds all these characters and grounds
all these figures why don't we speak on
route to Hogwarts experience Hogwarts
get that letter to Hogwarts and go to
Hogwarts the famed School of Witchcraft
and Wizardry ages since I've been to the
castle would be good to see the old pile
of rocks this is the game that that
they've dreamed of for 20 years
Avalanche software knew how important
this moment was to so many people they
knew it would resonate in a profound way
with Harry Potter fans from across the
globe but before they could reach that
moment they wanted an intro that would
show fans they weren't only capable of
making an action RPG in The Wizarding
World but that they were the perfect
studio for the job there's no doubt
Avalanche had the advantage of working
with a massively popular series but in
many ways this made the challenge even
more difficult Harry Potter first
debuted all the way back in 1997 and has
now been translated into more than 80
different languages one of the many
reasons for its worldwide appeal that
spans across vastly different cultures
and a wide range of Ages not only that
the immense popularity meant the game
would even reach those who don't
consider themselves Gamers crafting an
intro much less building an entire game
that pleases all or even a large portion
of those audiences was no easy task not
counting the Character Creator there are
four major sections to the intro we
start with a brief scene in London then
go on a carriage ride that's interrupted
by a fire breathing dragon explore an
ancient ruin with our mentor and then
take a trip to grots which brings all
the elements of story and gameplay
together across these scenes Avalanche
needed to accomplish three things they
needed to build trust create Intrigue
and educate players in order to build
that trust especially with the most
dedicated fans it's important to
immediately look and sound familiar but
to also demonstrate an understanding and
respect for the world there's a delicate
balance to making sure you respect this
world that we all know and love while
also telling a brand new story we have a
start of term feast and an assorting
ceremony to get to wonderful idea the
moment you're finished creating your
character Hogwarts Legacy opens with
this shot a shot that places you at the
center of the adventure ah it appears we
are almost ready to depart it's not
Harry Ron or Hermione positioned here in
the middle it's the character you just
created the opening takes place in
downtown London rather than any of the
magical locations fans would instantly
recognize this actually mirrors the
opening of the first six books all of
which begin firmly in the Muggle world
it's only as they progress that small
pieces of the Magical World start
trickling in thank you Professor fig I
appreciate you working with me before
the time begin here we have a handful of
visual cues that longtime fans are sure
to spot immediately there's an owl
perched at the back of the carriage a
carriage adorned with Hogwarts crests
the character on the left also holds a
wand as does our main character there
are no horses for the carriage even
though the Coachman appears to be
holding on to something and preparing
for travel but as we make our way
through the introduction we delve deeper
into the Wizarding World the touchstones
for longtime fans become more frequent
and more evident have you seen
this Marin's beard how did
you that key you discovered was clearly
py
R even though things look and read like
an adventure from the magical world we
know there's another crucial element
that's absolutely vital to bring all the
pieces together the one thing we felt
like is that the Brilliance of John
Williams's hedwig's theme he hadn't even
seen the movie and he wrote that
incredible piece of music we were
thinking about the idea that what if
there was an older Melody of lore that
might have been an earlier version of
hedwigs
[Music]
every time I play a video game The Sound
uh enhances the experience so
much ah it appears we are almost ready
to
depart it can be kind of tricky to know
what to write to know what notes to play
not every moment in the game has music
not every moment in every film has music
but when you need it it makes all the
difference
lumos and yet even with stunning visuals
and a magnificent score it wouldn't be
able to carry the experience without one
of the most important elements of
Storytelling Intrigue how extraordinary
it is indeed none of the faculty has
ever heard of anyone being admitted to
Hogwarts so late before I could respond
I received this what's that
glow I don't see a
clow nor do
I Marlin's beard how did you wa now that
we're sufficiently intrigued conflict we
did hang
[Music]
on
in the leadup to launch I was confident
Avalanche would nail the atmosphere
everything they discussed and showed up
to that point made it so incredibly
clear how dedicated they were to
respecting this world but this wasn't a
new book or film which are both more
passive forms of entertainment compared
to video games sure those experiences
consider their audio audiences but video
games must actively engage them players
are the ones driving the experience
after taking the port key with fig we're
transported to an unknown location and
even though I'm just a dad who loves
games and the stories they tell there's
something even I must rate as being more
important than a good story at least
when it comes to a video game and that's
having quality engaging gameplay take
this it's wig and weld potion that stuff
will write you in a
second I can read books or watch movies
to experience a good story but when it
comes to a game I want to explore the
world and its story in new ways and
that's a very unique quality of video
games after all if the game itself isn't
fun to play Chances Are many players
won't finish to see the story anyway as
we make our way through these ruins
story and gameplay begin to merge we
have an important conversation with fig
even though we're now moving through the
environment at our own control where do
you suppose your wife got the PK key
that brought us here a good question
Miriam spent years searching for
evidence of a long forgotten form of
ancient
magic so much of what makes enjoyable
gameplay is how it feels to actually
move within the world what's it like to
run jump change direction and in the
case of Hogwarts legacy cast spells
let's see some of that one work you were
practicing focus on the
center
excellent I love how immediately after
learning how to cast spells you come
across these clay pots scattered on the
ground it's almost like the devs knew
precisely what players would do
next your one works improving with every
cast thank you sir now Avalanche has all
the pieces in place they're ready to
combine those gameplay and story
elements they've already established and
bring them together in an epic sequence
at an iconic
location welcome to gring got's
Wizarding Bank to this day the gring got
sequence remains one of my favorite
moments in the game there's just this
Rush of nostalgia as we take our own
cart ride through the oldest sections of
the bank after you there's added
Intrigue as the story threads continue
to unravel the aland that God was where
it was glowing there's also a nice
little twist I wonder if you the
instructions for Vault 12 indicate that
I am to Grant access to the holder of
the key and then close the door door
wait
backck Professor that was certainly
unexpected we start learning Spells at a
more rapid Pace let's see what we're
missing shall We Ready your wand and
focus perhaps you should cast lumos look
out
prot and we're introduced to the
outstanding combat system which makes up
a core element of the game
play and it's here they also start
paying off on some of those earlier
moments of intrigue the wi your wizard
who completes the trials will have
proven themselves worthy of that
knowledge and the responsibility that
accompanies it all of this leads up to
our first encounter with ran Rock the
leader of the goblin rebellion and why
are you
here no no need for that just give me
whatever it is you found here and we can
let bygones be
bygones wait I'm not giving you
anything well perhaps your young friend
here will be more
helpful to me it's only fitting that the
Keepers refer to their challenges as
trials for the player because just as we
complete their first trial so too has
Avalanche completed their trial now
there's just one thing left to do when
people engage in The Wizarding World
what's the one anchor like what's the
thing that everyone comes back to what's
the thing that grounds it all and
grounds all these characters and grounds
all these figures the castle itself is
one of the most complex things we've
ever built this Grand space the dream
that it has been I'm sure for many
people to be there be in that space
every note is like a brick in the castle
and if we can put all those pieces
together we always pull the magic out of
the hat right out of the last moment who
would you be what kind of student would
you be that was at the heart of the
fantasy that we felt like we wanted to
deliver on it seems those who set up the
pensive the locket and the path to both
wanted someone with your
ability to end up here that school that
famous School of Witchcraft and Wizardry
is really what binds it
all we have a sorting ceremony to get
[Music]
to